how many people here have bought
something on wish the shopping app raise
your hands raise it high own it don't be
scared cool how many people here have
never heard it's cool I need the honesty
here and everyone's very [ __ ] like
this how many people here have never
heard of wish the shopping app raise
your hands this is the best moment of my
life one more time you have not heard of
wish the shopping app raise your hands
high okay this is the best
thank you very much wish depending on
who you listen to because it's a private
kind of thing company is doing anywhere
between three to six billion dollars in
revenue which is probably the closest
thing to any kind of conceivable threat
to Amazon in the world which is doing
three to six billion dollars in sales
they're spending 98% of their money
outside of a Lakers Los Angeles Lakers
patch on the Jersey and the McGregor
Mayweather fight they bought the corner
outside of those two activations they
were spending 98% of their money on
Facebook ads wishes founders are
engineers from Google that worked on the
Google AdWords product wishes doing
three to six billion dollars in sales
and more than half of this room this
room not some [ __ ] random hundred
people on the street in London this room
more than half of the people don't even
know what it is that is the punchline
thank you you got your perspective
wanna be happy don't you want to be
happy
[Music]
how many people here are entrepreneurs
and run their own business raise your
hands so for me just hi just for my own
context so for me this group more than
anybody is the most interesting because
for them I can comfortably say every
dollar you do not spend on Facebook and
Instagram during this era you'll regret
not spending I can't believe how much
I'm spending because what really is the
conversation that's not being had in
this space is what we all need as brands
or entrepreneurs or individuals which is
a lot more content if you really deeply
understand how many people here on the
media side like our media practitioners
of Facebook just raise your hands so
these individuals that just raise their
hands they deeply know that that
especially when you really know it that
the vulnerability / the opportunity is
we need a hell of a lot more content
that's contextual to the planning
capabilities of the platform the the big
aha
the big thing that I would love for
people to leave here if it brings them
value is understanding that I'm
producing a hundred pieces of content a
day from my brand and I'm probably a
thousand to four thousand short of what
I should be doing I I failed to almost
all my classes but one class that I got
A's and B's in consistently was history
and it's really interesting how that's
played out in my career I would implore
all of you if you really want to get a
an input to what I think is happening
here if you if you if this conversation
involves in the next hour and it's
valuable I would implore you to watch
the first 100 commercials made for
television the first 100 commercials
made for television which is been widely
fine on YouTube were radio ads they were
somebody holding up something or an
image and then a man read a script and
so a radio ad was put and made into a
television commercial
America runs on bull of a time because
we as a creative advertising field in
the industry and the businesses hadn't
figured out what the television
commercial was to me the most
interesting thing is in 2018 I think
most of us agree we've all accepted that
taking a television commercial and
putting in your Facebook feed or YouTube
that doesn't work I think we all kind of
got there but there is a far bigger 301
to that 101 point of view that needs to
be talked about which is okay but what
does the while we're at the commercial
shoot let's shoot some collateral and
use that for Facebook is also a very 101
point of view if anybody is producing
TVC and not producing a hell of a lot
more content while they're there they're
already disproportionally behind the
reality of the things that we should be
doing way more importantly to me is
should it be interpreting that spot or
should we be changing out actors and
actresses that demographically would be
able to be powerful to the people
consuming it should we be bringing other
products and things there that allow us
to shoot completely different things I
think we have a very weak creative
conversation around the new channels
because I think we come with a
perspective from the old world I have
empathy to why that is we you know one
of the biggest mistakes that people make
is they make decisions in a focus group
of one I have never made a business
decision in my life based on my own
behavior that is laughable stupid and
just naive at best and ideologically the
kind of like it's just it's not a good
idea and so I'm fascinated by how many
people go into rooms and say Gary you're
right my fourteen-year-old daughter uses
Instagram great John you know it's it's
this is not about you where your three
friends or your 17 year old niece or
like what your grandma did yesterday
this is [ __ ] data at scale this is
black and white happened this is not
happening
this is incoming 90 plus percent of the
fortune 500
CBG brands are declining in market share
in their marketing behavior 80% of their
spend is either on television or
programmatic digital which is digital
2006 this is not confusing meanwhile Jim
shark and fashion OVA and Lola and
movement watches are going from zero to
25 fifty a hundred five hundred million
dollars in sales on 100% spend on
influencer Facebook and Instagram this
is not subjective debate like if a video
is funny this is what's happening in the
business world one of the things I
recommend all of you is at least one
time in your career make a fundamental
career change and go into an industry
with fresh eyes you will be stunned how
smart you will be I think that was my
great advantage I didn't know when I
started vaynermedia I didn't know that
media and creative was separate it was
just when I did at Wine Library and the
only way I saw the internet work and so
I just built that it wasn't smart it was
naive and practical and so my rant here
is predicated one thing this is a in
2019 to even have this conversation is
underwhelming in 2019 to even have this
conversation is underwhelming like this
has been proven this is no longer should
we guess there's countless examples now
the problem is for some people that are
in the trenches and have run stuff is
like anything if you don't play a item
right it won't work
unbelievable amounts of money have been
wasted on Facebook and Instagram because
of a million different things the
creative was not strong the targeting
and the creative was not contextual to
each other there's a million different
reasons why it's happened so you know
the ROI of a piano to me is zero to
Elton John it's been a billion dollars
like this isn't you know cool it works
but now what I think that Facebook's
and Facebook knows this my points of
view on Facebook's best practices
creatively
is something I fundamentally disagree
with because I think it panders to
reporting and things of that nature but
back to the creatives in the room like
you want to win creatively make
something that's good like make
something people want to watch like you
can't imagine what happens when you make
a piece of video content that's really
good that people watch for two minutes
and nine seconds all the way through or
50% of the way through and then you
remarket them with a call to action you
can't imagine you want to really believe
in marketing do that you want to really
believe in how marketing works let me
give you the quickest way you can feel
really good at putting your head on a
pillow and saying yeah this [ __ ]
actually works make a great [ __ ]
video target it properly get hundreds of
thousands of people to see quite a bit
of it and then remarket them for a call
to action and watch how many convert
you'll believe in marketing for the rest
of your life it works it's just that
nobody's natively building for that my
big thing is this I bucket into two
groups of people right now one the
people that work at companies and what
they spend their money on versus two the
people that have to feed their families
with the business of success and what
they spend their money on and when you
go look at the people that work at
corporations and spend money on the
media side and creative and what they're
buying and then you go look at
entrepreneurs who have to put food on
their table and what they're spending
their money on that will give you the
biggest indication of what I think is
going on tonight and by the way that and
I want to make this perfectly clear that
doesn't mean a CMO or a head of media at
an agency is a bad person stupid or
wrong it means that's the game they're
playing of course if your CMO of a
company that's internal mmm doesn't
score social but over scores TV you're
gonna allocate those dollars because
your bonus is predicated on hitting your
numbers and you've got to buy a second
car for your daughter humans humans are
why very very very big businesses go out
of business and so I'm super pumped
because a ton of huge businesses are
about to go out of business and not
because I want that carnage because I
love the merit of the market another
random thing this is just more like
fodder it is scary
how underpriced influencer marketing is
if you deeply understand it mainly
because humans don't know how to price
themselves some are completely out of
their mind and 120 thousand a post when
there were 300 dollars in media and they
bought their fans and you can tell I
love these [ __ ] with 4 million
followers on Instagram with like 9 likes
we know what you're doing dick but on
the flip side boy the long tail of
influencer marketing is fascinating
getting a thousand different people now
it's a lot of hand-to-hand combat it's a
lot of non-working media dollars to get
it done but in net efficiency to the
business result you're looking for it's
super real I think the best way to build
any brand is deeply deeply into truths
and authenticity right so when I started
putting out content for example I curse
on stage if you go look at my 2007
videos on YouTube I get murdered in the
comments section for cursing right far
less acceptable 11 years ago than it is
today
for whatever reason but I wouldn't waver
because it was just the way you know
when you're a Jersey boy this is just
how you [ __ ] talk you know and so one
you've got to be you all the way through
authenticity is such a like played-out
term but it's kind of like stereotypes
they're grounded in some truths
authenticity really matters high volume
of content not overthinking the audience
in the way that most people don't show
them true selves because they're worried
about losing certain people around
certain things thus they become Vennela
right to me if you're up into marketing
but also a Jets fan and also you garage
sale on the weekends and also you like
root beer and sneakers put it all out
maybe my marketing community doesn't
want the sneaker stuff but maybe they do
and so a lot of overthinking so volume
of content I think really being grounded
in the distribution of ads like the fact
that you can now again because the
Facebook brought it back target based on
employees of costs of companies just
think about your business you can target
content based on employees of companies
so literally your video could be hey
does your CMO know that
be the beginning of your video or like
please make sure you're head of HR knows
all of a sudden three people of the four
thousand that you targeted forward that
video to the head of HR this is back to
being a practitioner so I think being
grounded in the media capabilities
producing content and the final thing I
would say is make it consumable based on
them not on you meaning video audio
written word all if you can now if
you're shy in front of a video which I
have empathy some are then you shouldn't
do it but if you can do video it's the
Holy Grail because then you can strip
the audio for podcast and audio you can
eventually at first you can transcribe
but if you build up you can hire
somebody to transcribe it into LinkedIn
medium and Facebook posts and then also
you know what I put out a deck an 88
page deck recently I think it's titled
garyvee content model I literally just
gave all my like everything I do my
secrets for free it's out that you
should look at that the thesis is make
content and then interpret it contextual
to the channels right so maybe a quote
from this talk becomes an Instagram
quote with a picture on it maybe this
audio I for fact this talk will be a
podcast episode for me so things like
that so it's creating content from
content because you're busy and you're
one person so there's an efficiency of
content production from a masterpiece of
content that creates collateral that
makes the volume that you're looking for
more palpable than create it's more
documenting than creating which is you
can imagine makes it a lot easier
because the creating part is what holds
people back so the constant debate we
have at work yes is what should
frequency strategy be can you burn bar
people too much do they really get
annoyed do you even remember your ad so
they say three times what you're so I
think it comes down to like you know it
comes down to what you're bombarding
them with can the New York Jets bombard
me too much absolutely not
bombard away right can Milky Way candy
bars bombard me too much they sure can
cuz I don't really like it or consider
it but if they're creative is clever or
utilitarian or interesting what about
more importantly if they gave me four
different cream
instead of one this this question is
predicated on the lack of the thing that
I think people need to fill which is
more creative right I think you'd have
you know one could argue and my team
argues about this all the time to do we
just run the 13 videos that have been
proven to resonate with people in
perpetuity or do I keep creating new
stuff and what's the cadence the answer
is there's a level of both to the result
I think that I think it's a really bad
idea to keep showing people [ __ ] that
they don't want so that is for sure
that being said there's also a
conversation that should be had in our
industry which is difficult because of
the technology advancements of potential
reach an actual reach potential
consumption and actual consumption
meaning I would also argue you can run
that same Milky Way ad to me four times
I just might not see it the first three
times even though it's registered as a
view but the fourth I may you see where
I'm going so I think this is why we
desperately have to tie this whole world
into if Milky Way was testing how it was
doing in Dublin at sea stores over a one
month period
it'd be you'd get far better answers
than philosophical debate in all those
hours of the philosophical debate if my
company actually spent the right amount
of time in the meetings that we should
be spending I'd have 400 less employees
we're in meanings debating dumb [ __ ]
24/7 in this industry if we took half
that time and did it into doing and
testing and tasting we'd all be much
further along
you